a judge has thrown out Donald Trump's
lawsuit against the New York Times and
his own niece Mary Trump this one I know
many of you have been following and some
of you may have forgotten about this was
the big lawsuit where Trump was going to
really take them to task a judge has
thrown the lawsuit out and is ordering
Trump to pay everybody else's legal fees
isn't this the best uh The Daily Beast
reporting judge tosses Trump's lawsuit
against New York Times orders him to pay
all legal fees Trump sued the paper
along with his niece Mary alleging an
Insidious plot to grab his tax records
and publish them in a Pulitzer winning
report the judge has tossed out the
lawsuit and ordered him to pay attorneys
fees legal expenses and Associated costs
this does go back to 2021 when Trump
filed the lawsuit saying that the New
York Times three of its reporters and
his own niece marry Trump engaged in an
Insidious plot to obtain his private
records for a Pulitzer winning story
about his tax issues when the court
tossed out Trump's claims against the
newspaper and its reporters the claims
while the court tossed out those claims
the claims against the ex-president's
niece have yet to be ruled upon this is
Justice Supreme New York Supreme Court
Justice Robert Reed who said that the
defendants fail as a matter of
constitutional law and added that Trump
has failed to demonstrate any torsion
interference with the times when the
times provided his niece with a burner
phone to communicate about the records
so another instance of major winning by
Trump as you can see Trump's history
with lawsuits is really really tough
Trump paid 25 million dollars for his
scam Trump University you may recall
that Trump had to pay back two million
dollars for misusing I call it stealing
from from charity
but misusing charity money Trump had to
pay a 10 million dollar fine for
laundering money for an extended period
of time through his Trump Taj Mahal
casino that went bankrupt and so his
history with lawsuits is not very good
as far as paying the legal fees here
we all know what the most likely attack
will be from Trump or the tactic better
said he won't pay the fees he will then
get sued over unpaid fees he'll end up
owing more than if he had just paid the
fees to begin with but if and when he
ultimately does pay the fees it won't be
with his money it'll once again will
will be with donated money or whatever
the case may be and then the entire
thing will cycle once again we've become
very accustomed to this I don't expect
it to change anytime soon did you know
that half of Americans are deficient in
vitamins A and C as well as magnesium if
you keep your diet nutritionally
balanced all the time you can get
everything you need but half of
Americans don't and it can really impact
how you feel our sponsor athletic greens
makes it super easy I mix one scoop of
ag1 from athletic greens into water it
tastes great I get all of the high
quality vitamins and minerals I need
from Whole Food sourced ingredients I
don't have to Fumble around with bottles
capsules individual vitamins and things
like that I just don't have the time you
should see what's going on at my house
ag1 simplifies everything I'm covering
my nutritional bases for the entire day
super easy easy to stick to as well and
dramatically more cost effective than
getting all of these different vitamin
supplements go to athletic greens.com
Pacman for a free year supply of vitamin
D I've talked about vitamin D many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below